I know you do a show but do you really
believe in ghosts um I believe that
there is absolutely something there is a
there is a phenomenon that occurs
whether it is
a the once living consciousness of a
human being that's still lingering don't
know it could be interdimensional it
could be you know quantum entanglement
it there is a there is a I'm going to
ask you a question I want to roll that
tape okay and you tell me what what what
is this what happened cuz this freaked
me out so show look look at this Mom
Mom Sharon Osborne was found
unresponsive and rushed to the hospital
hey hey hey lights on now now now we
need an ambulance now what what what
happened there we have no idea and I'm
this isn't
just me throwing stuff out to get view
whatever for to to give it some context
this is uh we got this from the trailer
of the new season on your Travel Channel
show called night of Terror night of
Terror you took your parents in you took
your mom into this room mhm and then
when I read about it you said a it says
a demon or did you say a demon possessed
her I didn't I didn't I never said
possessed I I believe his his let's
let's break it down factually she passed
out and lost Consciousness for 20
minutes and even stopped breathing for a
period of time she we rushed her to the
hospital she was in hospital for 2 days
they did every blood panel imaginable
she had heart scans brain scans sleep SC
she had every test imaginable to try and
determine medically what happened to her
the only thing that was off was her
electrolytes were a little bit low I've
been slightly dehydrated before that's
never happened to me like have you has
that ever happened to you when you've
walked out a little too hard and she had
nothing previously going in didn't feel
anything nothing nothing she was totally
fine completely normal we were
joking 2 minutes before that happened
and everyone even the doctor goes well
She fainted and I I have the raw footage
obviously we have to cut it down for TV
but that's not fainting because what
happened when you faint you you're out
it was a very gradual over 2 minutes is
how slow she went out to lose cont
because I know when you're dehydrated
too you feel something leading up to it
like whether it's a headache or you feel
dizzy or something and if there was
nothing so being The Devil's Advocate
you're doing the show does it does what
happened to her correspond to anything
that you were specifically looking for
the the room that we were in allegedly
had reports of a very dark ominous
entity that's what that's what a witness
said they saw some kind of weird shadow
figure so we put my mom in there and
what we were
doing there's a weird shadowy entity
seen by a witness so I put my mom in
there yeah why not she's a tough cookie
she can handle it I thought um but we we
put her in there she had a blindfold on
and so there's an exper it's a sensory
deprivation experiment you kind of do it
as a way to minimize distraction if
you're feeling something hearing
something it's kind it's you're using
your body as like a a a tool if you will
um and yeah she just slowly sat back and
her breathing got really heavy her head
went back and over 2 minutes lost lost
all Consciousness and then went back to
perfect after the hospital uh she
regained Consciousness after about 20
minutes uh ambulance you know when the
ambulance got there and this that and
the other and they um and she was
relatively alert I think she was more
scared afterwards and um does she have
any recollection of anything in the room
nothing she says she remembers sitting
down putting the blindfold on and then
coming to in the back of the
ambulance wow yeah and I don't here's
the thing I've been for years doing I've
done over a hundred ghost hunting
episodes I have had very few experiences
that would lead me to believe that oh
that's demonic that's evil that's this
that's oh that guy got possessed or I'm
I'm the Ghost Hunter that's like that's
not that can't happen that's not real
that's made up that scratch in your arm
is cuz you rubbed up against an old
screw that's sticking out of this half
condemned building so when I I always
come at it from a well what could this
be in reality you know
what I like to deal in the
three-dimensional world before I start
going into the spirit realm and this
that and the other I can't explain it I
I've shown it to the footage to numerous
doctors they couldn't explain it even
even when we're at the hospital they're
like oh well She fainted and I showed
the footage to the doctor right you know
20 minutes off 30 minutes after it
happened and his jaw hit the ground and
he's like I have no idea what I'm
looking at so I have I've chosen to Peg
it as a paranormal event that happened
to my mom could it have been some kind
of evil spiritual attack sure and also
it's a teachable moment if there is a
dark entity an evil entity report in a
room don't take your mom
no